fauci bombshell not convinced
kova 19 developed naturally outside
wuhan lab the hill story
anthony fauci the director of nih uh
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases and president
biden's chief medical advisor supporting
open investigation of the coronavirus
origin says earlier
this month he is not convinced or
developed naturally when asked about
whether the virus originally natural
naturally fauci said that he wants to
look closer to the matter according to
fox news
i'm not convinced about it i think we
should continue to invest again that
what happened in china
until we continue to find out to the
best of our abilities what happened
faculty says speaking of
politifact katie sanders at an event
certainly the people who investigated it
said it was likely the emergence from an
animal reservoir then then
that then infected individuals but it
could have been something else and we
need to find that out so you know
that's the reason why i said i'm
perfectly in favor of the investigation
that looks into the origins of the virus
he continued the white house has not
prepared
evidence to refute the lab leak theory
with press secretary jim paske saying
the biden administration is concerned
that the chinese government was not
transparent from the beginning
really thoughts you know um dr fauci i'm
going to say his name right
okay he loves himself some fauci doesn't
he i mean he
loves being with the news he loves
himself some fauci
um he loves being on television he loves
being in the news
he loves doing press conferences so i've
got a suggestion for dr fauci
go on shark tank launch the fouchy
flip-flops
right a little pair of shoes summer's
coming up beach it'd be perfect he could
make millions on it
here's here's my and by the way kai
check your email i sent you a little
something that maybe we can pull up here
in just a second
you know pat fauci adam you guys know
people like this right
they're overpaid and they know it right
i don't know if there's some sort of
phrase for this but people that know
they're not worth the money they're
being paid
there are people like that they're cc
suites you know people that have
you know somehow gotten to high-ranking
jobs they know they're really not quite
good enough for not qualified enough for
and they're making big bucks so they
have to seem like they're
they're worth it justifying it every
single day that's how i look at fauci
he's the highest paid government
employee numero uno
no one makes more money than him he's
the highest paid he goes out that he's
insecure
i can read this guy like a book he knows
he's not as smart as everybody
is claiming he is and acting like he is
by the way when's the last time he
treated a patient
if you're going to be the number one
doctor in the country get the
stethoscope out
i want to see you in a lab coat get
under a microscope once in a while
be a freaking doctor okay not a by the
way
kai did you find this okay he's going to
pull something up here i have a new role
for
you for dr fauci so when we're ready for
that kai i'll announce what i think
fauci should
focus on going forward okay adam what
are your thoughts
i think when tom hears the name fauci
triggers go off he's just that's what he
and uh
i don't think he's alone i don't think
he's alone i don't think he's alone on
the left or right
okay a lot of people feel let me see let
me say something i am not pro fauci but
i am certainly not
anti fouchy i think he's had a tough
freaking job i think when this thing
manifested in china there was nothing
anything we've seen like this in a
hundred years
and he was maybe a little over his head
but i think genuinely he tried to do his
best job
when he said back in march we don't
necessarily need masks
he came back and he flip-flopped on that
and that's been held against him for
a year now turns out maybe we didn't
need some freaking mess
and he had to and he didn't we did okay
and he had to reverse on that
however the bigger story here is this
continue
to investigate china this isn't about
fauci this is about
china at this point whether china
whether he's overpaid or whether he's
coming out with a new line of flip-flops
is freaking irrelevant what's important
here is investigating china you did an
interview with a lady
and who came out and basically came out
and said
i was a scientist working in a lab in
wuhan
and i can tell you conclusively this was
invented in a lab in china and then what
happened to that interview pat
yeah that's what's crazy when i did the
interview with the lady what was her
name by the way she was just on
tucker a couple days ago she was all
over the news she came out and she
talked about kyle you're looking up her
name or no
she was all over the news they were
talking about she says this is
remember this of course so we
interviewed her and the interview in two
days got half a million views
then they took it down yeah and we
didn't understand why they took it down
they also took down a judy mike of its
interview
the big tech overlords judy used to work
with fauci
in the 80s during the aids pandemic that
was taking place so so the biggest
challenge i have with fauci is the
following
fine that you're saying now yes we need
to look into it
but why is the fact that so many other
people said we need to look into it why
were they censored
exactly that's the hypothetical to me so
so you
how many billions of views was taken
down just because people questioned
the source of where it came from how
many actually curious still don't think
about that
it got to a point that you didn't even
want to post videos because they were
striking
they were putting strikes on it they
were taking it down so there's a part of
it that a lot of audiences
and by the way we look at our content on
valuetainment we used to get a lot more
recommendation than we do our views used
to be
75 by recommended from another video
that recommended list is pretty much
flatlined for us we don't get
recommended anymore like we used to
valuetainment's list on valuetainment we
used to be recommended on
75 of our views 50 to 75 of our viewers
were
it we don't have that number anymore why
i don't know i i'm not speculating
yeah i'm just stuck with that though and
by the way i'm not even going to the
point of shadow banning or whatever
people want to say if you do want to do
that go ahead and do that hey audience
you know what i tell about the audience
get even more on notification share the
content even more that's on you if you
really want to see this stuff being
shared
share it even more be part of a group
that we need to get this message out
there more i don't think enough people
people are sitting there kind of saying
this content makes sense rather than
saying this makes sense let me share
with 10 people
we need to get the ability to share even
more people need to be willing to share
the content more
but that took place to us last year i
kind of sat there and i'm like
really just because somebody said that
this could have been from the inside in
china so
the silencing part concerns me i applaud
fauci
for saiyan we ought to look into this
good for you but he should have said
that
seven months and he shouldn't have
stopped right now at on the earth
exactly because when rand paul just a
couple months ago asked him the question
he laughed at the idea he laughed at the
idea
and now you're changing your position
look john kerry years ago was supposed
to be the president
i don't know if you remember or not yeah
he was supposed to he was supposed to be
the president
until he got caught what flip-flopping
he was the ultimate flip-flopper
okay the guy went to i think he went to
yale i think he's one of those guys
that went to all the right schools he
was about to be the president he got a
lot of heat for what
one minute you're saying this one meant
you're saying that you're saying this to
the audience you're saying that to the
audience it should have been bush he
should have been the president
flip-flopper vouchers starting to
flip-flop a lot and people are getting
pissed off
make up your damn mind with everything
politicians flip-flops though
he just made the point found she's a
politician he's not a doctor
he's another member of the cabinet if
you ask me he is not a doctor
he is who is a doctor no he literally i
will give him that he's as much of a
doctor as doc severson was when he was
the leader of the tonight show band
no he is a doctor i will give him that
he went to medical school he is a doctor
okay but act like one okay be a doctor
if you're gonna be the top doctor i have
high expectations for you a little bit
more than just going which way the wind
blows which is what he does
look he's a cabinet member the guy's
been the guy
again i'm not pro fouchy but i'm not
anti-fouchy like you
the guy's been put in a tough position
this virus came out of china
he's he's been in the how long has he
been there through 40
years almost which means it's time to go
okay granted i'm just saying he's been
through
republican presidencies democratic
presidencies he's been around the block
he knows more than most so so for
someone who's like rand paul who's a
freaking
eye doctor to sit there and try to
battle fauci yeah but timeout
wasn't random paul ultimately right i
mean what do you say yeah i don't know
well she's now agreeing with that a lot
i think rand paul's been wrong more than
right
he's still a doctor rand paul eye doctor
it's not about it's not
a doctor of infectious diseases versus
an eye doctor i'm going to take fouchy's
depending on your brain but also
okay so fine but here's here's a
question here's a question for you
it's not about whether rand paul is
right or wrong
it's about the fact that what the hell
is wrong with questioning
anything i'm cool with that no it's not
then if you are cool with that rand paul
is not saying he's right
no he is rand paul is asking and
questioning which is totally fine
what you which you as a person who was
responsible for the world
relying on your opinion the world was
affected by a virus that came out of
china do you not think we need to go
figure out what the hell happened in
china do you not think we need to go i
know what the hell happened
rather than saying it's probably not
them what do you mean it's probably not
them by the way here's a q
here's another question for you how much
money
is the right amount of money to spend to
find out if they actually did this
intentionally
how much whatever it takes infinite
amount that's the point there why
why is it so important because it could
happen again because if it is true
if it is true you know what this is
called if this is true
you know what this is called this is not
a j this is how many people got killed
because of covid what's the latest
number because of kovan millions
what is the number total death of i'm
guessing
total number from kobe total death
3 million that's my guess that what's
the total number
uh uh not just u.s worldwide 2.6 million
point six yeah okay do you realize uh a
holocaust how many people
six million okay i was just jews that's
the number in total it was
10 million 20 million so you've heard 6
million to 20 million numbers okay
armenian genocide million people one and
a half million plus another half a
million greeks plus another quarter
million assyrians right
cambodia do you want me to keep going
you're going reparations is that where
you're going are you
kidding me of course are you kidding me
if you
did this you need to be held at the
highest are you
so here's what to me everybody needs to
put their money up and say what the hell
happened
and they need to be held accountable
this is not people don't by the way
this wasn't even that deadly this was a
one percent virus
if this was a five percent do you know
what that is
if this was if this this thing's are not
score was even higher
than what it is you know what this could
have looked like twenty fifty million
whatever the arnold score was higher
okay yeah which is the the share a bit
the
the the fact that it spreads faster if
it was higher
and more deadly dude what are you
talking about like a couple of us
wouldn't be sitting here right now
do you realize like like think about
you're not here right now i'm not here
right now
he's not here right now he's not here
right now a couple of us wouldn't be
sitting here right now
so the point is rather than saying it's
trump's fault this sir stop
where did it come from let's go to it i
don't care if it costs money
let's find out rather than sitting on
the sidelines and saying
oh let's get biden elected oh let's get
trump elected forget about all this
politics
what the hell happened let's get to the
bottom of this all this political games
they're playing
is getting old so the fact that fouch is
finally saying
we have to find out great put a budget
behind it
what's the budget let's go if china
wants to play ball
and they did this rather than sitting
there saying what are we going to do
with
the the what do you call it the yeah we
have a lot of import that's coming from
that we have 80 percent of
pharmaceuticals that's coming from we
have 70
of the chips that are coming from there
really that's what so
you're gonna keep empowering these guys
over and over
if this is true this is reparations at
the highest level
this is i did it to you and i can get
away with it you can't do nothing about
it yeah and they're working on the next
one
it's an act of war really i mean they
need to experience people in the country
and to investigate
what point is yes we should investigate
of course we should of course we should
put a ridiculous budget behind it
not only the united states the entire
world should do this but the question is
is china going to allow people to
actually go into the lab
but let's just say they don't question
people okay fine let's say they don't
let's say let's say they don't tax that
ass what i'm saying to you
say they don't yeah okay like you know
how people say you know how
there's cops will go to a house and they
say i know this guy's a murderer but you
can't go on unless you have a what
a warrant a warrant okay what if they
still don't let you in what do you got
to do you're going to knock down that
damn door and what if you can't do that
with china what do you got to do well
you're not going to knock down china's
door because what is our form of
knocking down the door
spy what is
the world has to do this it can't just
be the united states alone this has to
be a global coalition to say
i'm sorry ah buddy we gotta come in that
door india is willing to do it
u.s is willing to do it australia's
willing to do it canada is willing to do
it the eu's willing to develop korea so
put everything together
that's the point so if that's where
we're going and what i'm saying to you
it's if fauci's gotten to this point
this is great news i like the fact that
vouch has gotten to this point and i
like the fact
that the the spanish what's her name
spas
pasque sasaki uh whatever her name is
saki
uh says not transparent from the
beginning
the the the biden administration is
concerned that the chinese government
was not transparent from the beginning
you know what i'm sensing here let me
tell you what i'm sensing here right now
one the one one of the things america
desperately needs right now
desperately needs right now is the
following you know what 911 did
democrats want to help chase down
republican kids
republicans went out and said hey mary
what's going on i can't find my husband
i'll help you let's go
for people forgot about people people
just said what do you believe red white
and blue
great let's go today in the world 2.6
million people died you know what we
bleed all of us
red it's not red white and blue right
now let's figure out who the hell was
behind us yeah how this took place yeah
so and guess what
anybody including that virologist that
went and said this was a man-made guess
what
let's listen to them what's the
statement in america when somebody gets
charged with a crime what is it called
innocent to what proving guilty you know
what let's hear what you got to say tell
us you know and now people are basically
saying what she said wasn't crazy i mean
you know maybe you put that video back
up on youtube here's the other thing to
follow and watch is you're going to see
the mainstream media
you know echoing these same statements
that maybe it was coming out of china
and they're already starting to do it
cnn
washington post new york times npr
they're all kind of doing the same thing
when they mocked it and ridiculed it
you know a year ago now they're saying
hey maybe now here's my problem with
voucher you know i'm not a big fan right
i think he's the mascot of the
coronavirus that's literally what i
think he is but here's my problem with
him
people take their marching orders and
their cues from him um when he comes out
with two masks
and he's always got a fearful message
that's what he's always throwing out
there it's gloom and doom it's never
positive
you still see people driving around with
masks while they're driving their car
you see people walking outside no one
around them they have their masks on
healthy looking people i saw chris paul
yesterday wearing a mask when coach
williams was talking to him
two days ago and he's at the asylum like
dude what are you doing wearing a mask
when he's about to go in
he's he's playing he puts his mask on to
sit on the bench are you like serious
post-game interviews there were
masculine
sitting on each other sweating on each
other and that's my problem with fauci
because he just goes the way the wind
blows but
he's got a voice he's got a megaphone
and people fall for it
you talked about jon stewart jon stewart
has become famous for the last 10 years
for doing what
speaking out on behalf of both sides
first responders yeah from 9 11
that's right so i have an idea what's
that i think there needs to be a global
uh public hearing a coalition a a
full-on testimonial testifying in front
of a
world response global pandemic uh
supreme court type of thing
and get out there and have people
testify as to what happened globally
uh what's the what isn't there a global
uh what's a
the world court what's it called anyone
uh by uh
by uh uh there's a name for it yeah
the global coalition uh court whatever
the hell it is
something whatever it is yeah keep going
people need to get out there and testify
just like that jon stewart does and he's
always in front of uh
congress testifying on behalf of 911
there needs to be
a unilateral triglyceride court whatever
the hell the word is
uh and the this needs to be out there
here's the question
what percentage of this do you think was
at percentage the odds
that it was man-made versus a bat and
wuhan
i'll say 80 or higher i mean 80 man-made
yes i think china's back they're
laughing at us i'm thinking about the
next one that they can unleash
pat so if i do the call i have to keep
the phone here right is that what you're
telling me
or no it's going to be on there uh i'm
gonna say ten percent ten percent
ten percent that it was but let me tell
you what i mean by ten percent uh
uh i'm i'm extremely skeptical so i'm
i'm but i'm not
a i'm i'm skeptical but i'm also
not convinced it was 100 percent you
know man-made i'm saying 10
but to me 10 is still a high number yes
i'm not one in 10 chance that this was
man-made
why i uh i think honestly
uh uh trump was negotiating so
hardcore with them that they just said
watch what we're gonna do to you
i think this was a vendetta china had
against trump and
uh if that is uh if that if that's my
ten percent is that though
that's my ten percent my ten percent is
trump was getting in the way because all
the other politicians had made it easy
for china to compete at the highest
level and trump made it
very difficult so they said we gotta get
we gotta get rid of this guy so let's
throw a thorn in there and here
you know you're ten percent kai what are
you percentage it was man-made go ahead
um probably like five five percent
you guys percentage man-made
i would say five two oh my god okay i'm
gonna rash go ahead sam what do you got
i'm gonna rationalize my eighty percent
no i said it's at least fifty percent
fifty percent
why would we ask the audience guys
percentage that you think it was
man-made tom's at
eighty percent pat's at 10 i'm right
around 5 10 percent as well
i think 80 percent is a good time let me
ask you a question wouldn't you be more
5 or 10
if the timeline was flip-flopped now
government fauci media is all saying
it's a very good chance
they weren't saying that at the
beginning and then a year and a half
later they're saying no it came from a
bat crazy aggressive tom but that's all
good
that's what's your number i said five to
ten percent i said it that's where i'm
at let's get our audience in there
yeah if you're watching this a lot of
people are saying fifty percent yuri
says fifty percent
kate lemon says a hundred percent a
hundred percent right gifts as a 20
angry happy says ninety percent uh uh
joshua tomer says 69
he feels like i think he's a little
single right he's watching yeah he's uh
elon musk yeah so we got a bunch of by
the way a lot of people are saying on
the
like on the high end i haven't seen
anybody at five percent or ten percent
everybody's on a hand well
it is what it is so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye